we spent some time talking about
hydrocarbons and hydrocarbons are
interesting especially if you want to
combust things if you want some fuel but
now we're going to make things a little
bit more interesting by adding things to
the hydrocarbons and the things we're
gonna add we call functional groups
functional groups and my goal in this
video is to give you an overview of the
major functional groups that you might
see attached to carbon backbones that
make the molecules interesting
biologically now the first one I will
focus on is an OHA up so you have an O H
attached to a carbon backbone over here
it doesn't have to be attached to a
carbon backbone but the O H right over
here this is called a hydroxyl group
hi-hi Drakh SIL group and when it is
attached to a carbon backbone like this
one is then it turns the entire molecule
into an alcohol alcohol this is an
alcohol and this one in particular if
you want the name we have two carbons
all along its longest chain and it is an
alcohol so we use a prefix F for the two
carbons so let me write that down we're
gonna use the prefix F because we have
two carbons here and we're gonna say
ethanol F null which you might more
commonly know as rubbing as rubbing
alcohol now what are the properties here
well you have an oxygen which is very
electronegative bonded to a hydrogen and
to a carbon but the oxygen is a lot more
electronegative than the hydrogen so
you're going to have a partially
negative charge at this end away from
the hydrogen a partial positive charge
at the hydrogen end and to a lesser
degree at the carbon end - but hydrogen
is even less electron is a less
electronegative than even carbon and so
this one so a hydroxyl group they are
polar they are polar and because they're
polar you can dissolve them into into
water they are hydrophilic they can form
hydrogen bonds so you can dissolve this
now a similar a similar functional group
or one that has somewhat similar
properties is right over here and you
might say wait why is this one similar I
have I have sulfur here instead of
oxygen but if you look at the periodic
table you will see that sulfur and
oxygen both have six valence electrons
they both would love nothing more - than
to grab or pretend to grab
two other electrons and this is why they
form they tend to form two covalent
bonds and so this group right over here
which is called a sulfhydryl group this
is a self self hydral self hydral group
it's it's kind of similar to a hydroxyl
group with the one difference with the
one difference that sulfur is
electronegative but it is less
electronegative than oxygen so you're
still gonna have a partially negative
charge and a partially positive charge
but it's going to be less polar so it's
not quite as polar as if you had a
hydroxyl group now when you have this
self hydral group it's attached to say a
carbon chain and when I when I use this
R right over here when I have this R
this is just shorthand for carbon and a
bunch of other stuff I could have if I
wanted to generalize an alcohol right
over here I could have written R and
then I could have written the hydroxyl
group O and then bond that bond that to
an H so over here this shorthand R would
have been the shorthand for all of the R
would have been the shorthand for all of
this business all of this business right
over here and so that's what we're doing
over there I'm not saying that this R is
exactly this it means it's some you know
carbon backbone and some and other
carbons hydrogen's and maybe other stuff
maybe even some other functional groups
but we're just focused on the self
hydral right over here and so if you see
something like this you'd say okay yeah
this is still gonna be polar but not
quite as polar as if I were dealing with
a hydroxyl group now over here we have a
more complex molecule but this is a
molecule that you run into probably on a
daily basis this is the sugar fructose
this is the sugar fructose and this is
this is what it is not in a ring if you
were to throw this in too if you were
throw this into water it'll readily form
a ring but it's not in a ring form you
can recognize already the hydroxyl
groups you have a hydroxyl group on this
carbon you have a hydroxyl group on this
carbon hydroxyl group on this carbon you
have a hydroxyl group on that carbon you
have a hydroxyl group on this carbon and
then on this carbon you it's double
bonded to an oxygen we call this a
carbonyl group so this is a this is a
carbonyl
urban eel carbonyl group and this is
actually how you would tell a sugar is
like it look especially when it's in a
straight chain all my carbons I have a
Hydra have one hydroxyl on them except
for this one it has a carbonyl group and
one of the takeaways for a carbonyl
group we've already talked about oxygen
being very electronegative even more
electronegative than carbon it's double
bonds it's going to hog the electrons on
the oxygen end so you're gonna have a
partial you're gonna have a partially
negative charge partially negative
charge over here partially positive
charge over here and so this this one is
also going to be polar and in fact the
entire molecule is very poor because it
has all these hydroxyl groups on it as
well but this is also going to give it
polarity here and because this carbon
has a slightly positive charge it is
susceptible to nucleophilic attack and
when you take organic chemistry you'll
see that things that that that want to
want to share that that have a
predisposition to to share their
electrons and a bond might want to come
and and form a bond with this carbon and
maybe one of these these electron pairs
go back to this go back to this oxygen
and maybe bond with something else but
we'll talk about that in the future when
we study some organic chemistry
mechanisms the important thing here is
just recognize okay I got some hydroxyl
groups hey I got a carbonyl group right
over here as well now this molecule this
is an amino acid and you will see amino
acids a lot when you study biology and
this has actually a couple of
interesting groups on it the first group
of note is this is this stuff that I am
circling in orange because you have a
carbon that is you could say it's part
of a carbonyl group but it is also it is
also bound to a hydroxyl group it is
also bound to a hydroxyl group right
over there and when you have this
configuration where you have a carbon
bond double bonded to an oxygen and then
single bonded to a hydroxyl group we
call this a carboxyl group this is a car
carboxyl carboxyl carboxyl group and one
of the takeaways from this is that it is
acidic because this can readily give up
the hydrogen proton this oxygen we
already know oxygen likes to hog
electrons
it can take up both of these electrons
and become negative and actually there's
actually resonance here because those
electrons get shared throughout the
group and actually even potentially even
beyond the group but especially inside
of the group and then leaving the
hydrogen proton so this can readily
donate a hydrogen this can readily
donate a hydrogen proton so this is is
generally viewed as acidic acidic now
this this this amino acid over here it
also and this is where this name comes
from actually the acid comes from this
carboxyl group that's the acidic part
and then you have an amino group you
have an amino group right all right over
here and because it's involving nitrogen
this is the amino group this is what
gives the amino part of the name amino
acid amino acid and this is actually
generally basic because nitrogen could
it has a lone bear it has a it has a
lone pair of electrons right over here
and so it could use that lone pair to
pick up to form a bond with a with a
hydrogen ion to pick up a hydrogen ion
so under the right circumstances it can
form a bond with a hydrogen ion which we
know a positive ion which would just be
a proton and so it would have a positive
charge and so since it can hop up
hydrogen ions we can view this as the
the amino group as being basic but this
right over here is leucine it's an amino
acid super important for muscle growth
but there you can appreciate you have
essentially a hydrocarbon chain but it
has a carboxyl group at this end and an
amino group right over here and another
thing that you'll sometimes people talk
about is even hydrocarbon groups for
example if you consider the main chain
of this and we could consider it either
using this carbon or this carbon but if
we consider this to be the main chain of
carbons if we consider that to be the
main chain of carbons then we would
consider this right over here to be a
methyl group remember the prefix meth
refers to one carbon so it's one carbon
bonded to a bunch of hydrogen's to 300s
here and so we would call this a methyl
group and in general if you have a
hydrocarbon bonded to other hydrocarbon
groups these things are are hydrophobic
so these things there's nothing
Poehler about them and so they're not
going to want to at least this parts
these parts of the molecules are not
going to naturally dissolve inside of
water now the last group we're going to
focus on and you're going to see a lot
of these and especially in biology
you're going to see it as part of ATP
you're going to see this a backbone of
DNA and that's phosphate groups and this
right over here this right over here is
the phosphate group I've drawn it bonded
to a bunch of kind of a group over here
who knows what it is a bunch of carbons
a bunch of other things and then I've
monitored it to two hydrogen's but it
doesn't always have to be bound to
hydrogen's but when it is bound to
hydrogen's like this is considered to be
pro its protonated and so it can
actually take up it can actually hog
these electrons and dump these
hydrogen's and dump these hydrogen's
into a solution so a phosphate group is
considered to be acidic it is considered
as well especially when it is protonated
like this it is considered to be acidic
because it can donate protons so this is
just an overview of a lot of the
functional groups you will see
throughout biology and a lot of big
hairy complex molecules when you
actually break it down you say okay
there's a hydrocarbon chain there oh I
see a sugar there I see a bunch of
hydroxyls and I have a carbonyl group oh
I see an amine group I see our amino
group I see a car Bock a carboxyl group
you can think about is this going to be
acidic is it going to be polar or do
different parts of the molecules have
different functions